Oprah and the Rock are being slammed
because they raise the fund they donated
10 million dollars of their own money to
support Maui and they asked their fans
to help support as well and they're
being slammed because they're worth 2.8
billion dollars my take on it is we need
to support people who are trying to do
good
you know we criticize people for not
doing more instead of recognizing them
for what they are doing how many people
live on Maui big celebrity rich people
who've done nothing or made zero public
appeal Bezos has a place on Maui Larry
Ellison has a place on Maui he's worth
150 billion dollars you're getting upset
over Oprah and rocks too he's worth 150
billion has he done something Clint
Eastwood lives on Maui lots of
celebrities but live on Maui and listen
Maybe lots of people are doing things
but Oprah and the Rock are taking it
public and I think when you criticize
people who are doing good and see if
they're not doing enough
other people don't want to come forward
and do good where we need to celebrate
people doing good